[Music]
my name is guy
sunday should be warm and sunny just a
scattering of drive-bys
and i live in paradise
i've got a best friend this is the
greatest cup of coffee of all time
mondays am i right joe you said it guys
and i work
at the bank
i thought i had everything i needed but
then
i met her everybody down on the ground
everybody accept you
please i have a cold fist there's
something inside you guys i don't want
something inside me i expected you to
just follow the rules but you are so
much more than that i'll put these on
okay fine oh my god
what are these trick glasses or
something guy there is no easy way to
say this
this world it's a video game you're not
real
please
and stop guy responsible for this world
was going to destroy it
you've met god yes he's an absolute
troll trolls exist
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters
i am sitting here with my best friend
trying to help him get through a tough
time now that's not real
i don't know what it is i know this
world is just a game for this place
these people that's all i have
so i'm not gonna be the good guy next
guy i'm gonna be the great guy
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity off you go
this whole good guy routine is ruining
the game
terminator it's the first time i've ever
driven a car before
i really wish you'd mentioned that yeah
that actually hurt my hands we can save
our world
but we have to fight together
[Music]
nope
i can't die
[Music]
foreign